computers have made our lives more
effortless than ever however computer
viruses have been trouble since day one
on that note hey guys welcome to yet
another exciting video by simply learn
this video brings you the top six most
dangerous computer viruses of all time
but before we begin if you're new here
and haven't subscribed already make sure
to hit the subscribe button and the bell
icon for interesting tech videos every
day so moving on here's a list of the
most dangerous computer virus let's see
what we have at number one
at number one we have maidu
maidu was one of the worst computer
virus outbreaks in history in 2004. this
malware is technically a worm spread by
mass emailing
it broke previous marks set by the so
big worm and i love you to become the
fastest spreading email worm ever email
spammers appear to have hired my doom to
spread spam by a compromised pcs
users will open an attachment named mail
transaction fails that will be sent to
the victim its objective was to take
down popular websites like google and
lycos
my doom cost estimated damage of 38
billion dollars in 2004 but its
inflation adjusted cost is 52.2 billion
us dollars
by that figure my dome has taken on a
life of its own infecting enough poorly
protected machines to send 1.2 billion
copies of itself per year 16 years after
its creation my doom one of the most
widely distributed viruses infected one
out of every 12 emails at its height
my doom hit companies like google seo
group and microsoft with the distributed
denial of service attack in 2004 16 to
25 percent of all emails had been
infected by my do
on that note here's a question for you
which is the latest deadly computer
virus you have heard of do let us know
in the comment section below
at number two we have i love you the i
love you virus of 2000 spread by
delivering a fake love letter that
appear to be a harmless text file this
attacker like my doom sends copies of
itself to all of the email addresses on
the infected machine's contact list it
had spread to over 10 million pcs within
a few days after its may 4 release
arnold gusbin a college student from the
philippines invented the virus he
created the wires to collect credentials
to log into internet sites he wanted to
utilize for free since he was shot on
cash according to reports he had no clue
how far his work would travel love
letter is another name for this virus
at number three on the list of dangerous
computer viruses we have code red code
red was a computer worm that emerged in
july 2001 and infected computers running
microsoft's iis web server
the code red worm had been released on
july 13th but on july 19 2001 another
variant of the worm spread rapidly and
was reported to infect over 250 000
computers in just nine hours on that day
the total number of infected hosts
reached 359 thousand
the worm defaced the affected websites
to display the hacked by chinese text
string it was the first large-scale
thread that could successfully target
enterprise networks in august 2001 the
guardian reported that the fbi had
issued serious warnings to organizations
asking them to safeguard themselves
against this worm at number four we have
crypto locker
the crypto virus popularly known as
crypto locker is a ransomware virus that
encrypts files on a computer and demands
a ransom in return for a decryption code
the crypto locker malware spread between
early september 2013 and late may 2014.
the primary means of infection was via
phishing emails with malicious
attachments it was identified as a
trojan virus that targeted computers
running different versions of the
windows operating system once the crypto
locker is launched it encrypts many
files on a user's computer or hard
drives servers and other storage devices
throughout the organization
cryptovirus attacks are rising with over
4000 attacks each day as per the u.s
government estimates more than one
billion dollars is paid in ransom each
year
at number 5 we have melissa the melissa
virus was one of the biggest and
earliest cyber threats in history
released in march 1999 melissa started
spreading via email infecting thousands
of computers within hours the virus was
sent in a file called list.doc which
contained passwords to censored websites
so when users downloaded the file and
opened it in microsoft word a macro
inside the document was executed and
emailed the list stock file to 50 people
listed in the user's email alias file
email servers at more than 300 companies
and government agencies worldwide became
overloaded and some had to be shut down
entirely as per the u.s fbi report the
estimated cost for cleaning and
repairing affected computer systems was
18 million dollars and finally at number
six on the list of most dangerous
computer viruses we have slammer
on saturday january 25th 2003 the
internet was hit by a vicious computer
worm known as sql slammer it brought
down most of the world's sql servers and
slowed down internet traffic
bank atms were down slammer was 376
bytes of malicious code that attempted
to connect to every computer it could
find over ms sql udp port 1434 causing
heavy network traffic it is believed to
have infected over 75 000 systems within
10 minutes sql slammer was the fastest
spreading computer worm in history the
new york times reported that microsoft
admitted that some of its machines had
gone unpatched and that its msn internet
service also had significant slowdowns
due to the slammer worm so that brings
us to the end of this video i hope this
video on the most dangerous computer
virus was informative and helpful
thank you for watching the video and
stay tuned for more from simply learn
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here